الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
كين الرياض الصالحين
جمعه
الحافظ الفقيه المحدث
ابو زكريا يحيى ابن شرف النووي رحمه الله
تعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فاذا قضيت الصلاه
فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل الله
واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم تفلحون
الله سبحانه وتعالى سازوره
الجمعه
صلاه الجمعه
‏Go forth and spread through the
seek of the bounty of Allah and remember
الله
often and much in order that you may all
obtain
واذكروا الله كثيرا
this here
one of the way
الله سبحانه وتالى allows something
allowance
is
what we refer to ز مباح
ما هو المباح
المباح
الذي يعود امره الى
ال
المكلف
ليس عليه وزر بفعله
ولا عليه لوم بتركه
ان سو وهذا حكمه سو و از مباح مباح
‏is ne for they to
this neut
way
have
‏norally
after
that we are not
areرام
احرام
فاذا حللتم
فاصطات
هل معنى هذا الكلام
انه من مناسك الحج ان الانسان
اذا حل
من احرامه
وجب عليه او استحب استح تحب له ان يذهب
يصطاد لا بل هذا من صيغ الاباحه في ران
[Silence]
‏comm
and the way neutality articulated inر
here have
we are
comm
to
buying andelling
areج
صلاه جمعهمعه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وذروا البيع فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا
البيع
الله
جمعه
فاذا قضيت الصلاه فانتشروا في الارض
انتشروا في الارض هذا اباحه
يقول
وابتغوا من فضل الله هذا ايضا اباحه
[Silence]
‏neutan
gover you and
you don't have to but you you may
واذكر الله كثيرا
now
changes
why
الله سبحانه وتالى
not
going
through the
الله
[Silence]
جمعه صلاه الجمعه specifically
this is time for theance of
الله سبحانه وتعالى
the people of the book before us because
of their disobedience
they were
prohibited on their
weekly day of worship they were
prohibited from working entirely
‏was
to
was
all those things and time
of
however
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏have
best of days as we
and as we will hear the best of days and
not only that but we are allowed
if we
fulfill our oigations
towards Allah and worship on the day of
jum
ولله الحمد
‏Arab langage
in the Arabic langage me
the day when a person is not permitt
to and is a to the right
of on that
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
الجمعه
‏name جمعه
الجمع جمعه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
انسوا الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز واذكروا
الله كثيرا لعلكم تفلحون اذا هذه الواو قد
تكون للاستئناف يعني جمله جديده يقول
تعالى فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل
الله انتهت الجمله الجمله التاليه واذكروا
الله كثيرا لعلكم تفلحون
ويؤخذ خذ استحباب زياده الذكر في يوم
الجمعه بعد
ما ينفض الناس من الصلاه بعد انقضاء
الصلاه من الجو العام ومن السياق
وقد
يكون المراد هنا بالواو انها عاطفه
لكن عطف جمله على جمله يكون المعنى
فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل الله
و فاذا قضيت الصلاه اذكروا الله كثيرا
لعلكم تفلحون
وعلى كل كلا المعنى المعنيين
ا متقارب ومتلازم
يقول وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه قال قال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم خير يوم
طلعت عليه الشمس يوم الجمعه فيه خلق ادم
وفيه ادخل الجنه وفيه اخرج منها رواه مسلم
هريره ابو هريره
عبد الرحمن ابن صخر
الدوسيوس
طيب
[Silence]
take
easy way to remember
18 is
معاذ بن جبل خلاص
رضي الله
‏tyrant is going to
takeance
over the
in the coming year this was narration
that he had from the prop
and to
الله
مروان بن عبد الملك
office
الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي
عراق
ب
الله سبحانه وتعالى
دعا
before
رضي
الله صلى الله عليه
‏on was
and on was enter and parad
and on day he was
he was
taken out of parad
so this is mentioning the virtues ‏of
the day of Jum
why is him being taken out of parad of
virtue of the day of the day that
he was created and was also the day wasm
into parad
was also was out of parad
why
anyone
اه
صحيح هذا شيء اخر لكن
هذا الحديث في سياق
او في سوق
فضائل الجمعه
فيعدد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
يوم الجمعه فيه خلق ادم طيب ماشي هذه
فضيله ليوم الجمعه
في خلق هذا الانسان هذا البشر العظيم
الشان
وفيه ادخل الجنه ما شاء الله اختار الله
تلك اليوم لادخاله الجنه طيب وفيه اخرج
منها كيف هذا الاخراج يكون من فضائل
الجمعه
[Arabic recitation]
هو تاب على ادم في
يعني قبل اخراجه من الجمعه وبرضه لو كان
هذا هو المقصود لقال وفيه تاب عليه وفيه
تاب على ادم
[Silence]
‏allح
وى
parad any happ withoutentam
parad
notam
that wasqu
‏because we
right
and was paradنا
ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا والله
اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
[Silence]
fingers fingers